money can actually buy happiness but
only about 10
of it if you tell me how much money you
make i can tell you how happy you are
going to be in your life
but only by 10 because the other 90 of
happiness
is related to how you process the world
around you and your genetic makeup
which means that 90 is up to you
hi i'm amy blankson i'm the founder and
ceo of fearless positivity
i researched the intersection of
happiness technology and
well-being and today i'm here to debunk
some myths that we've all heard and
believe
about happiness you either have
happiness
or you don't it turns out that some
people
are actually born happier than other
people some people
are born predisposed to be more
satisfied than other people
and some people have a harder time
finding that level of satisfaction
researchers found that only 10 of your
happiness is due to your environment
the other 90 is due to your genes and
your perception of the world the key
here is that it doesn't have to be the
end of the story
despite your genes we all have the
capacity
to increase our happiness levels and to
practice happiness overall
happiness looks the same around the
world happiness takes on a different
sense of meaning
and context of the cultures around the
world if you're a scientist and you're
trying to study and measure
happiness we actually look at something
called subjective
well-being which is the metric being
used to measure happiness on a global
scale through the un global happiness
report
the un global happiness report comes out
every year reporting on the happiest
countries in the world
and every year consistently the
scandinavian countries
topped the list the question is why do
these countries
consistently show up as happier than
others what makes them happier countries
if you're familiar with masel's
hierarchy of needs you know that
shelter and food are the bedrock of
being able to reach a level of
self-actualization in your life
so having those taken care of and
provided by those countries
enables individuals to pursue other
passions that help them to move up
the triangle for happiness but other
countries that maybe are not as wealthy
also top the list what's interesting is
that a number of countries
who have high levels of social support
have been
indicated to be some of the happier
countries so if we're looking for a
culture that is going to embrace
and create a global level of happiness
the fastest way to get there
is by providing social support to those
around you
there's power and positive thinking
happiness is actually something that you
can get better at
we've learned from scientists over the
past two decades from the field of
positive psychology
that our mind has incredible power to
change our scenarios and our life
situations
and we can begin to train our brains to
think this way
by doing a series of exercises that i
call the j game
it's a cheesy mnemonic that i use to
remember journaling
gratitude acts of kindness meditation
and exercise the j game when i talk
about journaling we're talking about
taking
two minutes to write down the most
meaningful moment in the last 24 hours
of your life what were you doing
who are you with and why was it so
meaningful in doing so your brain begins
to relive the most meaningful moment of
the last 24 hours
helping you to actually re-experience
that
because your brain can't tell the
difference between visualization
and actual experience and as a result we
find that your brain begins to relive
this moment
and feel a double sense of happiness the
second habit is
g g for gratitude what we're trying to
do with gratitude
is to retrain the neural pathways in
your brain to begin to develop a new
reflex
and how you're seeing and thinking about
the world we can't be both positive and
negative at the same time
so when your brain is practicing
scanning your environment
for positive things your brain can't
literally look for all the negative
things at the same moment
you're beginning to all of a sudden find
new ways to scan your environment for
the good
and over time this becomes a reflexive
habit
that changes your outlook on life the
third habit is a for
acts of kindness i recommend you take
two minutes a day to
thank or praise somebody in your social
support network
you can do so by text by phone in person
or even a handwritten letter but what
happens when you send
a quick message to somebody saying thank
you for something that you've done
all of a sudden you create a positive
feedback loop that not only makes the
other person feel happier
but it also makes you feel happier and
so you begin to create a virtuous cycle
m for meditation
i recommend you take two minutes a day
to simply watch your breath go
in and out when you
meditate other people around you pick up
the benefits of your meditation
even if they don't know you're
meditating this comes back to something
called
the mirror neuron effect and the mirror
neuron effect is an
incredibly powerful response based on
the fact that humans are wirelessly
connected to one another
the last habit is exercise exercise is a
bit of a started drug
i recommend that individuals pick one of
these five habits to try for
21 days in your life this is up to you
and you can get better at happiness
if you make happiness into a work ethic
success
leads to happiness researchers have
since found
that the exact opposite is true
happiness
leads to success we keep thinking i'll
be happy when
i'll be happy when i get good grades or
i'll be happy when i get into
college and then you get into college
and suddenly you need to get a job
and then you need to get a promotion and
then you need to buy a house
and each time happiness gets pushed over
the cognitive horizon
and your brain never actually gets to
that feeling of happiness
the reason why is because we're chasing
after perhaps the wrong things
when we look after success as something
that leads to greater happiness
we're constantly looking for external
validation for our overall happiness
but if we can positively identify the
correct things that
actually drive meaning and satisfaction
on a deeper level
then we're actually moving towards being
the person that we want to be
those are the things that create
long-term satisfaction and happiness
money can't buy happiness money can
actually buy happiness
but only about 10 of it if you tell me
how much money you make i can tell you
how happy you are going to be in your
life
but only by 10 because the other ninety
percent of happiness is related to
how you process the world around you and
your genetic makeup
which means that ninety percent is up to
you
so no matter how many houses you buy how
many planes you own
it won't necessarily impact your
happiness and in fact
it might have a decreasing effect
research finds the individuals who are
more wealthy
actually reach a point at which their
happiness begins to decline
with increasing money we find that there
is the law of diminishing returns in
economics that says that there is a
benefit to
things like money for a certain amount
of time
and then after a certain point there's a
steep drop off social media
makes us unhappy many individuals feel
as though social media
is making us less happy overall by
creating levels of social comparison
creating and increasing cyber bullying
and leading to
a lot of insecurities about privacy but
social media is not to blame
it's about how we use it challenges of
social media
is a level of social comparison always
looking to
other individuals in your immediate
environment who
perhaps are living a better life or
their lives seemingly
are perfect but when we look at our own
lives we start to wonder
maybe i should be doing something
different and you feel less satisfied
the fastest way to make someone less
happy is to compare them to someone else
we often say that comparison is the
thief of joy
so looking at social media the key is to
be able to
limit the amount of time and exposure to
social media that actually benefits you
that helps you feel connected and the
moment of which you begin to find
yourself comparing to somebody else
to step away and maybe even if you need
to take a digital detox
thanks so much for tuning in today my
goal is to leave you feeling empowered
and to know that you can make a
difference in your happiness levels
that it is within reach and that you can
become a best version of yourself
by striving after your potential good
luck